so I told you that ona was Sussex that
we use for something this big large a
lot alright so in Italian you can modify
nouns and we do it all the time it's
very very common well what do we do take
the route over now and then we change
the suffix based on some characteristic
that we want to emphasize if something
is big it's small it's cute it is bad
and so there are a lot of the sub sub
fixes really a lot of a lot i want to
tell you just the basic ones well so
basic we have a dining table
so something is small then so for
example this is one Kalia this is small
yeah you know me so you see they have a
same route we changed the subject so it
goes from yah yah yah yah yah you know
eon or hear another example let's see
cherry tomatoes how do i put calculators
so it's pomodori because right or
perfecta a little perfecta with you
Terry already right oh well okay grab it
so cigarettes protect apologies for that
then becomes put it in now or what 15
there's another team i so apprec ego
when something is very light yellow
dress warm right so for example well I
have a friend where a lot of friends
named paulo that's a masculine powder
okay and in the town where I grew up
there were lots of Paolo's of different
sizes so tallest one we won't hold him
how long they are holding power so from
oh it becomes 0 morning
oh sorry oh yeah why they were calling
me calling up or call it down together
yeah so someone who is them good also
love to you but yeah yes someone who is
a fan who you can save somebody's baby
boy where does it become water follow a
boil so yes yes but it's a lot but you
you can turn an adjective into a now not
yet was also what also yet oh god always
someone who has a big nose NASA
zone nazanin Scalzo casona khazana casa
so causal oh sorry yeah in a sense ok
what does concern is so Khalsa culture
means soft and you see here the
resounding very interesting that happens
sometimes when you're using these of
negative like a sheet evo it also
changes gender because we've got such a
large culture would be cut so now una
zona it's family room okay but in this
case Calzona relative illness Sufism
Whitson Jack Ebel let's eject he was
something that's endearing or cute it's
a cinch ja whoa whoa so let's be
suffering samples of fits in Geneva I
told you for example when I was growing
up but also now a lot of people instead
of calling me shower and I go back home
they call me Polly not falling Oh
he comes it's endearing to me it's like
on the shoot little house I like the car
okay for well for example and back it's
herb you can say oh I grow herbs in the
garden and give you are attached to your
herbs because of you keeping watering
down every day's ok and then you say oh
questa and back in touch to your uncle
I'm glowies deal with the day become you
see a gradual and yet so the will to see
ya yes stop and then we blast on the
barren searing today is pig jority book
so it hurts and obliterating so when
something is bad ugly a new things you
don't like it then you use big charity
Finch yes Joe yo la teeth see whoa whoa
I'm little difficult with jealousy but
surface is actual or yes or you ain't a
pizza you didn't lie to fit such very
good keep some thumbs or if you have a
nice that's very sharp or in your very
dangerous that you can say acting CEO
net a quelle what de la la or for
example fedora Holland's word hot cha
what is it no single know if I would
like to have better you know that your
say bad words I donut and making you are
angry if your brother brother is yes
when you say ah you neyo rapid latch oh
I'm the particle nest sure yeah that's
fun right and because a lot a lot a lot
a lot and I took a hookah yeah bit
beyond temples
I'm not gonna be a whole fable or you're
gonna fall asleep I chose a couple of
excerpts so the author is Johnny Johnny
so when you have instead of breathing
key I say job Johnny Johnny road I and
he's really very famous Italian writer
and journalist mean he's dead now but
they're still very very popular and
these books are particularly popular for
his his books for kids but the most
popular so you don't you know what to be
during the summer but maybe some short
stories but John you know Donnie it's a
good idea is the per couple of its fun
he uses about the present tense I just
want you to read you a couple of
excerpts so you see that Tom this is
this subtype Jack in action okay so this
is just the beginning of this talk one
vago in trauma what did i say when i go
and sandra always always Oh snoring
antiparticle see Rachel you seen your
actual very good and bad [ __ ] bad oh
it's always your uncle Abu kha bucha
I snakehead call my own Warren nozzle on
she know our children she was a hooker
they got a people become a big Larry so
this man is pick on people you can
repeat the same objective twice pickle
pickle pickle or you can say Nicolino
exactly so this man is really really
good article and at some point he's just
start shouting and he says promote
anything repeteme pretty sure means yes
somebody who is a bully high-end
distortion promote anything but an open
prepotent acho oh you see so it's not
just a freak okay bully he's using that
a job right of thing nacho yeah and
while this is I don't thank you the
stories just the part the other story
which is I think it's a story of
confetti technique a day oh yes as far
as I got off at laughter it's a talking
crap i'm not going to redo the whole
story but the idea is that the cat is
the his cat and he's writing a letter to
Johnny otay kenyatta so he's resting
Carlo Johnny
yet he'll so no I am a cat jt8d Warner
funny guy I come from a good planning
yeah madre era la baa laga no cat puke
glossa you grassed balusters deeper
[ __ ] up Vinny tahoe portable it is
part of me on this very day is another
city but for 10 minutes support ice door
it's only to the old doors of nearest
neighbor so grasa is fat you got a key
Becky got Tony great with a dog big cats
so you see there is the of mine that the
Oni don't know the old peek at dean
lanham citicorp dunno this member Lakota
turn me on oh no remember we have always
pop something like this a record ah yes
oh yeah music yeah cold um who else
would yes so what is this was that Jesus
grandfather had a very big Koda run
Dakota if you want to use your main
event the tip what will you say oh don't
go unicode ona cookie oscoda era chunga
what I'm touching team oh that's like
having their owners yes fundamental
window and sin gamma it looked Zach
Holden equal Cavallo
it's like the tail of a horse and more